[Music]
all right 6 25 on your wednesday morning
we're learning more about some of those
little noticed mysterious signs you may
have seen near southern nevada freeways
viewer
alex i don't think it's our alex i had a
question that you might have wondered
about too like
what is the deal with signs like these
around the city saying it looks like
they can alternate between an interstate
and the u.s highway sign with room for
info at the top and bottom
alex writes i've seen them on various
streets near highway entrances for years
they never got turned on well we have
another tip of the driving you crazy
hatching nevada department of
transportation spokesman tony earlier
for the answer he says
oh those are called trailblazer signs
that 136 of them were installed around
the valley in the early 2000s
he adds they are solar powered radio
controlled
is supposed to activate the event of a
closure that would help drivers navigate
around an incident
but man what a difference 20 years can
make tony writes that because of apps
like waze
and the new overhead freeway signs that
can be changed
as needed well he says they're in the
process of decommissioning what were
once seen as trail blazing signs tony
says they cost a lot to maintain they
won't be upgraded in fact says
they'll all eventually trail blaze into
the sunset
great question alex thanks for riding in
buckle up drive carefully please put on
that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com